[Music]
in nottingham's christmas market it's
business as usual but as people enjoyed
a festive day out came news that the
omicron variant has arrived in their
city
something that was a distant threat just
days ago
now very close to home
it's scary that's all it is yeah we're
scared of it i just hope we don't go
into another lockdown to be honest
that's the main concern just still being
able to
see family and do the normal everyday
things that we've missed out on
but as people headed out for the night
came confirmation that coronavirus rules
will once again be tightened the prime
minister's announcement including pcr
tests for all uk arrivals and compulsory
face masks in shops and on public
transport it's becoming a way of life
that's the worrying thing it's like when
does it end
it's gonna be hard to get used to it
again um
yeah it's gonna be rubbish
on the buses people finding out they'll
have no choice but get used to wearing a
mask again how do you feel about that
that
why because i don't i don't like i don't
wear never the face makes masks it
doesn't doesn't hurt we're one and it's
just looking out for other people and
yeah i don't think there's anything
wrong with reintroducing masks
but for many there's a sense of being
stuck in a never-ending cycle
over the last few months life has
returned to something that resembles
normality but the emergence of this new
variant and now the reintroduction of
some restrictions serves as a reminder
that the pandemic isn't over
now the fear that christmas is once
again under threat people need normality
they need families they need to see
people obviously safely socially
distancing
but i really think this christmas now
people's had enough
but the arrival of a new worrying
variant is becoming an unwelcome festive
tradition just as people were hoping
this christmas will be better than last
becky johnson sky news nottingham